you wake up at 8 a.m. in the morning and
your throat feels scratchy and painful
you have an intense thirst your head
hurts and you possibly have a fever yet
you still have work to do or some place
to be this isn't the first time this has
happened to you and if you live in the
United States you are one of the 30 to
40 million children and adults who
suffer from the same sword nests in
their throats every year yet you always
wonder why you hi and welcome to my
simplified today we will be talking
about sore throat a common painful
condition that has millions suffering
worldwide we will look at what causes
sore throat the signs and symptoms of a
sore throat and how do we treat a sore
throat and what can you do to prevent a
sore throat - so let's begin first let's
look at how a human throat is from the
inside the human throat consists of a
pharynx epiglottis and the larynx the
pharynx is connected to the mouth
allowing food and liquid to pass down
via the east of Vegas and allows inhaled
air from the nose to enter the lungs it
is the epiglottis which acts like a lid
and prevents food or liquid to enter the
lungs the larynx contain the vocal cords
and they help you to speak hence it is
also known as a voice box now that we
have looked at structure of our throat
let's look at what causes a sore throat
although there are various causes of a
sore throat they can be broadly divided
into infectious and non-infectious
causes infectious causes include
bacteria and viruses that can infect
your throat viruses that can infect your
throat our Rhino viruses which it causes
common cold influenza virus
mononucleosis virus measles and
varicella virus a number of bacterial
infections can also cause a sore throat
the most common being the streptococcus
pyogenes which is caused by the Group A
streptococcus and that is known as the
strep throat now there are many cases of
sore throat which are not caused by any
of these pathogens and these come under
the non-infectious causes of sore throat
these can include allergies especially
allergies to pets molds dust and pollen
can
also caused a sore throat sore throat
due to irritation with irritants like
tobacco smoke or chewing tobacco
drinking excessive alcohol and eating
spicy foods can also irritate your
throat sore throat can also develop due
to a strain in the vocal cords which can
be caused by excessive yelling talking
loudly or talking for long periods
without rest
gastroesophageal reflux disease which is
a digestive system disorder can also
lead to acid reflux into the vocal cords
and the pharynx and can cause a sore
throat tumors of throat tongue or larynx
can also lead to a sore throat breathing
excessively through your mouth can also
cause a dry sore throat let's look at
some of the signs and symptoms of a sore
throat pain or a scratchy sensation in
throat that worsens with swallowing or
talking difficulty swallowing sore
swollen glands in your jaw or neck white
patches or pass on your tonsils a horse
or muffled voice fever runny nose
sneezing body aches headaches nausea and
vomiting now let's look at some of the
danger signs of sore throat a sore
throat that is severe or lasts longer
than a week difficulty breathing
sore throat associated with joint pains
sore throat associated with earache if
you develop a rash on your skin and a
sore throat it's also a danger sign if
you develop fever higher than 101 degree
Fahrenheit during a sore throat that is
also a danger sign blood in your saliva
swelling in your neck or face is also a
danger sign
although anyone can get a sore throat
some factors make you more susceptible
these include age children and Dean's
are most likely to develop sore throats
exposure to tobacco smoke smoking and
secondhand smoke can irritate the throat
chronic and frequent sinus infections
bacteria from your nose can irritate
your throat or spread infection
close-quarters viral and bacterial
infection spread easily anywhere people
gather whether in childcare centers
classrooms offices or airplanes you are
more susceptible to infections in
general if your immunity is low common
causes of lowered immunity include HIV
diabetes treatment with steroids or
chemotherapy drugs stress fatigue and
poor diet also contribute to weakened
immunity
hugely sore throat is a self diagnosis
but let's look at how sore throat is
diagnosed in clinics the doctor will
start with a physical examination that
will include the use of a lighted
instrument to look at the throat and
likely the ears and the nasal passage
gently palpating or feeling the neck to
check for swollen glands also known as
lymph nodes listening to your child's
breathing with a stethoscope and many
cases doctors use a simple test to
detect step to avoid bacteria which is
the cause of strep throat this test is
the throat swab the doctor rubs a
sterile swab over the back of the throat
to get a sample of secretions and sends
a sample to a lab for testing
sore throat caused by viral infection
usually lasts 5 to 7 days and doesn't
require medical treatment to ease pain
and fever many people turn to
acetaminophen tylenol or adult mild pain
relievers
however if your sore throat is caused by
a bacterial infection your doctor or
pediatrician will prescribe antibiotics
regardless of the cause of your sore
throat
there are at-home strategies that will
help you to ease you or your child's
symptoms the first one of them is rest
get good amounts of sleep rest your
voice to drink plenty of fluids fluids
keep the throat moist and prevent
dehydration avoid caffeine and alcohol
which can dehydrate you try comforting
foods and beverages like caffeine free
tea or warm water with honey gargle with
salt water add one teaspoon of salt
to 200 ml warm water and use that for
gargling 8 to 10 times do it especially
before you sleep and you will feel a lot
better when you wake up in the morning
humidify the air around you you can keep
a pan of steaming water in your room or
use a traditional room humidifier
consider lozenges and avoid irritants
like smoking
the best way to prevent sore throat is
to avoid the germs that cause them and
practice good hygiene follow these tips
and teach your child to do the same wash
your hands thoroughly and frequently
especially after using the toilet before
eating and after sneezing or coughing
cough or sneeze into a tissue and throw
it away when necessary sneeze into your
elbow use alcohol-based hand sanitizers
as an alternative to washing hands when
slope and water aren't available avoid
touching public phones or drinking
fountains with your mouth regularly
clean telephones TV remotes and computer
keyboards with sanitizing cleanser when
you travel clean phones and remotes in
your hotel room avoid close contact with
people who are sick
so guys this was all about the sore
throat I hope you liked the video if you
want downloadable content from this
video and all our other previous videos
on my simplified you can join us here on
YouTube or you can also subscribe to our
community at patreon.com all links are
in the description bar down below thank
you so much for watching see you in the
next one